منتظرينا ومتشبثين باي فرصه تنقذهم من موت
وشيك فرصه وجدها هؤلاء تحت انقاذ الزلزال
عبر اجهزه الهواتف الذكيه وخاصيه البث
المباشر على مواقع التواصل التي لعبت دورا
اساسيا في انقاذ عدد كبير من العالقين تحت
المباني المدمره
اطلقها العليقون تحت الانقاض بتوثيق ما قد
يكون اخر ظهور لهم واخر لحظه عاشوها عبر
هواتفهم طلبا للنجده ونقل واقعهم
ومعاناتهم للعالم اجمع اثبتت القوه الخفيه
للتكنولوجيا فعاليتها في انقاذ الحياه في
ادق واصعب الظروف والكوارث الطبيعيه
امثله كثيره لناجين من انقاذ الزلزال لعل
ابرزها هذا الرجل الستيني علقه تحت
الانقاض لقرابه 103 ساعات
ساهم في مساعده فرق الانقاذ للتوصل لمكانه
بعد ان تواصل مع عائلته بواسطه هاتفه
الحمد لله
انا عايش بهذه الجمله بات الشاب السوري
مثالا اخر على قوه الهواتف الذكيه
بالانقاذ بعد ان صور مقطع فيديو من تحت
الانقاض مستغيثا باي فرصه نجاه هؤلاء هم
جزء من كثيرين كتبت لهم حياه جديده بعد ان
تمسكوا بهواتفهم الذكيه خاصه ان قطاع
الاتصالات لم يتاثر كثيرا بزلزال على
العكس تماما من شبكات الكهرباء
روان حمزه العربيه